[Music]
and welcome back to off the record where
we talk about whatever we want
and we've got dawn with us here today
which means we got questions don is a
special special man in the military
which is the marine branch of the marine
rangers
imagine all the branches of the military
it goes all the way up here don's like
right in here yep somewhere there
[ __ ] deal that's a big deal it's a
big [ __ ] deal not for being you know
like right yeah holy [ __ ]
playing counter strike you wish you were
doing yep don's job
yeah long time ago so recently don he
did this uh five mile
underwater like rock run thing which i
thought was super cool like what did
that want you to share the story
like what what's what inspired it
what might what made you guys choose
that as a challenge and who invented it
wait you did that thing in hawaii where
you carry the rock and you run under
yeah
i did it but not five miles and you did
it with the seal right yeah there was my
friend uh cars larson
the whole time when you're doing it
we're like i gotta [ __ ] beat this
guy's [ __ ] i gotta make sure that the
seal isn't i mean it started like that
but then it was just like oh help me out
dude i'm going to die
wait you do it together as a relay or
you do it against each other no we did
it we did it together like helping each
other out so we did like two and a half
miles each so how did you guys how did
you guys do it because when you told me
you said the whole thing took like six
hours and then like your your fingers
and body starts
getting cold because you're underwater
for that long yeah i'm like what
inspired you to do it and why did you do
it and why did you guys choose that
length and all of that because it
doesn't make sense
yeah i mean honestly well like why are
you walking five miles underwater but um
number one it was for um
this company that ten thousand that i
work with they have this thing once a
month called the feet of strength so
they're trying to show that average guys
can do really cool stuff but you guys
are on average though yeah
six miles rock running that's not
average dude yeah that's the kind of
purpose
this is a raider and a seal to do
average people's stuff
i guess i'm kind of average right but
then when i did the rock run i did it
twice from basically this distance to
that wall
back and forth and i was done bro
because the thing is you can't just hold
it and run you have to hold it and then
your breath runs out so you drop it and
you swim back up you get air and you
swim back down by the time you get the
rock again you got to go backwards you
need more [ __ ] air
you go back down you get two steps and
then you get back up and it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm just glad real people
did this [ __ ] not [ __ ] weird freaks
yeah it's all about breath control you
know
one mile would take me probably 10 hours
yeah but it is breath control that's
crazy when you were when you would get
the rock and you would start uh running
how
how long like time duration were you
able to run until you had to get more
breath yeah so we started off trying to
do 50 meter legs um
50 meter by the way is like the length
of uh half a football field they're
trying to do that in one breath and if
you're a wide receiver you get there in
like i don't know a second
all right just like for context
[Laughter]
you guys do this in the ocean
because the hardest thing
was timing the currents because when i'm
down there i realize that if i don't
time the currents right i'm running and
i'm not moving oh yeah so i'm taking
four steps and i'm like running out of
air and i'm like i'm not [ __ ] moving
and then you take one step and then you
go and then you gotta get up and get air
yeah we did it um
parallel to the shore so it was just
like ripping us back and forth just
doing this yeah
dude but it felt like from here to the
wall right
yeah
for real but when you catch a current
though that [ __ ] pushes you and you
don't have to do no work yeah
true but it's it's ridiculous man they
also train like that maybe he shares
about some of her business but they'll
like run with dumbbells underwater in a
pool so they they train for stuff like
that too exactly so that's where the
inspiration came from for the event like
hey what can we do to showcase um some
of the stuff i do for my company which
is deep in fitness um as well as like do
something extremely challenging for
people to do make it look cool wear the
shorts
pretty much would it would i be a [ __ ]
if i had an air tank in there and i was
running
yeah
that'd be useless like that wouldn't be
that that's [ __ ] that wouldn't be that
cool i guarantee you
that even with me with the air tank
holding the rock you guys will still
pass my ass
would i be a [ __ ] if i was down there
and i was like on a bicycle
like a water bike
water bike a regular bike
oh okay oh that's not that [ __ ] at all
thank you i think that's cool right [ __ ]
yeah yeah i got you would i be a [ __ ]
if i was down there but i'm quitting but
you can't really hear that i'm quitting
you'll die because it was a drown i see
thank you okay
but if you die you're not a [ __ ] you'll
get like a medal of bitchness i guess or
not because you didn't put out i mean
you put it out all the way you know i
mean you didn't come back up yeah see
how long can you hold your breath for
um three minutes 37 seconds i just
guessed
yeah
yeah i'm trying to do four minutes but
we'll see four minutes
that's a long [ __ ] most i've ever
been able to do is 90 seconds dude my
grandpa who by the way underwater
yeah but now i could only do like 40. my
grandpa was a lieutenant colonel in the
marines
he got drunk during bobbing for apples
and he held his breath for four and a
half minutes so
i think he got bobbing apples
i don't know about your time that the
wide receiver can make it halfway across
in one second
my grandpa held his breath for 14 days
straight
[Laughter]
i said four and a half minutes
i was watching this one documentary on
like uh filipino like divers oh they're
good oh yeah i've seen that one they
could hold their breath for five minutes
and they're just in there just like oh
like getting oysters or whatever and
that one dude enters the competition and
he nearly like passes out going back up
yeah
dude tom cruise doing like the what was
it the fifth imp mission possibly i
don't know i lost track but he had to
hold his breath for like five minutes
between takes or whatever or direct is
amazing
yeah but he was also breathing uh pure
oxygen before and he's also four feet
tall am i right that's true so
better
you say breathing pure oxygen like they
were giving them your pure oxygen take
in order to like activate your body's ox
like hyper oxygenate the so what ah
no it's still when you um blood doping
when you train to hold your breath how
is there like a method or you just hold
your breath and you go
and purple and then you let it go yeah i
mean it's always about like how well
your body translates uh the oxygen that
it needs to your extremities so like
your vo2 max and then as well as how
well your body um holds that
co2 your carbon dioxide or the tolerance
for it because
when you're actually the urgency to
breathe isn't the lack of oxygen it's
the buildup of co2 in your mouth oh
yeah sorry break a train to it push a
lactic threshold a little bit so the
more you train to it the better it is
because i lost it all
i stopped hold doing wim hof breath
techniques for like half a year and then
i tried to hold my breath again i
couldn't even do a minute we did um when
i went to go take this class
when i was going to take this class like
one of the first things we did was like
this burpee ladder so you would like
hold your breath do one burpee
and then let it out hold your breath
again do two burpees and let it out and
then three burpees so then that way
you're like training and priming your
body to be able to do work under breath
you just told me your program i didn't
have to pay for it
what's a warm-up this is a warm one get
the whole thing for free yeah but that
helped me
like because we did that before we even
got in the pool right so the purpose did
you do with your head breath hold help
we only went up like four or five or so
we did five yeah so we just did that and
then that already got my like confidence
up a little bit because his
their entire class is done underwater
wow but at 12 feet too so you feel the
pressure of the you know when you like
when it hurts here and it hurts here
like you're not doing it three feet
below the surface you're doing it 12
feet below the surface
so
you have to get really comfortable
because by the time you feel the urge to
need air you look up and you're like oh
[ __ ] i still got like another 5-10
seconds before i can get it yeah so it's
cool that we were doing the burpee so it
just feels uh
yeah mentally prep yourself yeah
actually everybody can hold their
breasts for maybe two three minutes but
it's my mind that [ __ ] is out yeah it's
your mentality
what's the philosophy behind like
working out 12 feet under
yeah so um we're actually doing a study
right now at asu kind of discovering the
real benefits to quantify it a little
bit more but
when you go underwater right and you
have the urgency to breathe you pretty
much are faced with like the fight or
flight
situation right like hey do i come up
for air or do i understand my body and
my capabilities enough to stay down and
then do the things i need to do at first
so the same chemicals are firing off for
you if you're in a stressful situation
you're in a gunfight you're in a meeting
at work robbery
robbery or whatever that is and you're
more adapted to those chemicals firing
off in your brain
sometimes i try to not come so fast and
i use the whole breath technique but you
come faster
[Laughter]
yeah oh [ __ ] but he's too [ __ ] to put a
belt around his neck like i do yeah i
put a [ __ ] belt all the way around my
neck i go three notches encourage guys
notches by the way i don't [ __ ] around
three notches okay he got a thick neck
too no no i heard that's a real thing by
the way actually
while you bust a nut yeah it is that's
how david carradine died exactly thank
you
robin williams no no no no no no david
curtin you think he you think he got
that last night before he died i hoped
it got i really hope he did i hope you
thought it was worth it [ __ ] up too
he was jacking off and choked himself
yeah in a closet i think
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's what
you do not feel such as stress pain
anxiety in the heart yeah and you know i
didn't think i would get flight anxiety
you just fly anxiety dude i used to
relax like crazy on the airplane and i
don't know what happened out of nowhere
now too flight anxiety is getting older
or even if i drive a little bit faster
whoa whoa whoa and it's like dude
what the hell man you need some cbd
right now that's exactly what i did i
got some cbd fields drops on my tongue
elations and i went
and i said i need to go to sleep because
there's no reason why i should be having
anxiety on business class right now
because this is fun that's true because
if you're on spirit you might need a
whole bottle yeah that's true
but thank goodness i just went to sleep
yeah and i woke up and i was like you
know what the combination of living in
luxury business class with cbd is
probably one of the best things on earth
because i was literally in the clouds
and in the clouds in the clouds floating
it was wonderful yeah that's awesome so
feels is awesome it's a cbd premium
service and you can just take a couple
of drops underneath your tongue and they
even have a hotline that you can call if
it's your first time you're like this
sounds awesome i do want to try it but i
do want to talk to people about it while
i'm doing it so they have a hotline that
you can call at any time but if you're
on the airplane though you got to keep
your phone on airplane mode or else the
pilot is pilot's gonna be confused so
you gotta talk to them before you get on
the airplane yep so you can become a
member today by going to feels.com off
the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's f e a l
s dot com slash
h e r e c o r d to get fifty percent off
plus free shipping thank you feels i
feel good
he killed his bill
she's stupid jacking off the dumbest
joke i heard about it was that he died
hard which you know outside
you know he did of course it's fine
i'd rather die harder than not genuine
question when you're down there right
you're holding this rock and you're like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] right
what how do you get that extra little
piece that helps you push through
it's all about calmness and relaxation
so instead of hyping yourself up
underwater you want to conserve as much
energy as possible right but if you pump
yourself up underwater your heart beats
faster that's true but what about when
you're like out mile one right and
you're like
[ __ ] i gotta do another like two or
three miles of this [ __ ] like what's the
extra thing that he's like
it's fine like you keep i was trying to
use those increments so we we ended up
doing 50 meter increments but taking one
breath at 25. so
for me it was like 17 steps going across
17. dude i get three good steps in and
i'm back up for a [ __ ] air yeah and i
come back down and then we switched
after 50.
but for me i was like there's a lot of
things going on my mind like [ __ ] do i
really want to do this
yeah how do you fight through all that
[ __ ] because he's got like my company
can't fail dawg you know yeah well i
mean it was like number one was like hey
i'm doing this to kind of rub camera's
off i'll be in the water turn the
cameras off yeah kind of rub my brand a
little bit number one i don't want to
fail to the seal you know i don't want
to lose the navy seal guy and then he's
a seal you gotta steal swim water how
long how long you do you're a land guy
what's up how long are you doing this
for we did for five miles okay six hours
another here's a really stupid question
are you like pooping and peeing in there
what's going on yeah i peed there i
didn't poop though i i didn't even eat
before i should ate before i was so
tired oh what oh [ __ ] i didn't think it
was going to take six hours you can
carbon load
no but i so i did a mile in the pool by
myself at like 40
like 40 minutes 44 minutes ish so like
oh i have another person doing it with
me it's going to be a lot faster were
you wearing goggles yeah oh cause the
hardest thing doing the rock thing for
me is finding the rock no goggles it's
salt water yeah
and then i by the time i find the rock
and i touch it i need air already yeah
have you ever thought about running with
the rock
and then when no one's looking like
[ __ ] just kind of heavy let me get
that done
erosion dude
erosion salt water really just
deteriorated yeah [ __ ] it up
i kept dropping it and it just broke off
i guess
we had this crazy rock from the north
shore lifeguards shout out to them but
it's like their sacred rock running oh
oh they have one damn they have a
designated
designated rock that's like a good place
grip hand to hold it
you guys did it in north shore yeah damn
yeah
at bay where there's no waves right now
but in the winter oh cool
has like five to ten foot waves in
waimea bay yeah
yeah is there a [ __ ] lot of coral
because that'll be a [ __ ] no it's
beautiful it's just sand other rocks
down there
you're like [ __ ] which one what's your
rocker a turtle two turtles that's dope
they're just what the [ __ ] is this full
shell down here in the front
i was in the nava bay and i was taking
out coral left and right
you were taking them out yeah yeah
[ __ ] you no it was i i just had flippers
on and i was like i'm six foot four and
a half i don't know the block on all of
[Laughter]
i think i should be banned from that
location
wear like water shoes or anything you
get blisters from all the sand
no but like so the water was like 76 or
78 degrees so it's pretty warm but if
you're in there for six hours yeah not
for six hours yeah your body tries to to
warm up the whole ocean so that we're
actually like about
we're getting really really cold so we
had to put some wetsuits on oh they had
wetsuits that you could we brought it oh
could you have like a safety boat
probably
yeah we had some safeties from the north
shore lifeguards as well um mo and uh
joey shout out to them they're awesome
but um yeah how deep did you guys go for
the running we were trying to stay
in between 12 and 15 feet
deep the whole time
okay let's get deep real quick last time
you were here and i really appreciated
your honesty it was awesome we did actu
ask the expert with you and it was
really fun um but you talked about how
you did like a mushroom trip and it
really helped you get through some [ __ ]
going on how are you doing now
uh i'm doing good i did another one um
dude it's a kind of a little recharge
but i did a dmt like uh
shaman
is that like the whole like dmt and like
the the new i guess the new
recharge i think it's pretty popular
right nowadays to especially like in
silicon valley and like the corporate
world
because it allows you to see life at a
different perspective which is the
biggest thing and sometimes people need
that stuff like so instead of like
looking at your problem set like oh
that's horrible for me and now you might
see it as an opportunity for growth
or you might see a company problem as it
as a in a different perspective so you
can help fix your company's problems
were you did you feel like your life was
like
like the the darkness or whatever was
closing back in so you needed to
recharge or it was just something like i
just need to go do it
i think it was both um so i originally
did like the first time so i have like a
[ __ ] ton of nightmares and stuff like
that so like when my nightmares come
back i kind of do that to like reset my
mind right because it's always about
um i don't know if there's like hard
studies on it but it's about
neuroplasticity right so how well your
neural pathways are created so like ptsd
or whatever that is they talk about or
combat stress or even stress from a
regular person
it's easy for you to recline those same
paths if you experience something so
traumatic right in that pathway in your
brain but what dmt or does or
psychedelics is supposed to renew that
pathway so you create new ones so it's
not as easy for you to recollect those
memories you can still collect them but
it's not it automatically happens like
if i hear explosion or whatever that it
doesn't automatically take me to that
place wow oh [ __ ] yeah so it helps in
that kind of explosion of flowers
yeah you got to rewrite history some
people see that is 4th of july rough for
you no no i [ __ ] love lying fireworks
one of my favorite things to do
so you you described your trip last time
did you have a different trip this time
uh different experience um yeah for sure
i think it's always different um going
into it and depending like what
intentions you set before
um and then how you kind of
guide that journey because i this is
like probably my third time doing it so
i was able to kind of facilitate it
myself a little bit more mentally
preparing for it not being so scared and
just letting it hit me as hard and i did
a lot smaller dosage was it smoking or
drinking you you smoke it did you do it
with the buddy or you go by yourself i
did it with my buddy and a shaman
tired as well
and the buddy he has a similar
experience with you he was in the
military with me as well um out of the
military now though yeah but so you guys
have like some sort of bond and it's
like it feels safe to do it it feels
safe space yeah
because you guys relate on the same
stuff huh and other people can't relate
yeah i mean you don't need to really
relate like we can have a completely
different issues or whatever it is but
if i am going with someone i trust
that's the most important part because
you're pretty much
it's out of body of experience so that
could be scary for people because you're
not within your own thought process or
like something that we might like throw
up or [ __ ] or something like that
uh you might throw up in ayahuasca but
for dmt yeah i don't think you will hurt
and i even think about that when i smoke
weed like i don't want to be around
people i don't know even if they're cool
because i get paranoid i don't like bad
vibes people yeah yeah but if you're
going to get high you want to be high
around people that you trust because
then you just feel comfortable around
them yeah yeah yeah you're right though
like
even if i'm sober i don't really wanna
have bad vibes yeah
one of my favorite genres i'm not
getting is uh
people's trips when they go on dmt can
you take us there can you walk like you
watch those videos i love those videos
dude i love it
this most recent one yeah um
feel free to exaggerate because we don't
know anything yeah it's okay so there's
there's multiple types of dmt pretty
much right there's a plant-based one
that comes off of a specific bark vegans
um and there's the otak toad one that
comes from the poison off that secretes
from like they literally lick a toad
yeah
i mean you can but they take the poison
off the toad they dry it up and they
crystallize it and you smoke it that's
cool just get into a question oh no i've
seen that happen yeah and then i'm
pretty sure ayahuasca is a combination
of two different plants that put
together that creates a dmt um as well
so those are the different types that i
know about
but
i just did the plant one this one so
um it immediately took me into like a
space of um
different geometrical shapes that turned
into um
like this form of a woman kind of thing
i love this drug already it sounds dope
but not like i couldn't see your face or
it was all just even better yeah um but
then like i felt like this huge pressure
on my chest like she just came rushing
down on me like pushing this all this
weight and pressure on me and i was like
it's kind of uncomfortable it's kind of
scary or whatever that is
um and then like i was like
but do you just give yourself to the
feeling or do you try to resist well i
was trying to resist it a little bit
more but then like at one point i was
like oh just let it go just relax just
let it go just relax and as soon as it
happens like boom
not like butterflies but like things
kind of dissipated and then i was like
in a space where
um i was i felt eternally like free like
wow just cool stress-free worry-free you
know um not happiness not sadness but
just like floating just floating like
empty spaces and i was like that was the
message for me was like hey sometimes
you need to let go of the things you
can't control and control the things you
can and then um have some knowledge to
know the difference of the two different
things how long did the trip last
thing with that one was like maybe 20
minutes ish because i hear it's pretty
short that seems like a long time 20
minutes your experience it's it's
probably like you actually you lose some
type of yeah
because that description sounds similar
to um uh lsd for me or when i took acid
one time but that that lasted hours lsd
is too long
yeah
but that's not like an out of body
experience you know it's like uh
dude lsd is like the lord rings extended
edition of lsd i mean back in the 60s
and 70s when they were testing lsd
people definitely wrote about some
out-of-body experiences i did it when i
was 14 years old and it was probably the
wrong time to do it
or the best time
that explains a lot
you guys want to do some mushrooms then
they they tested on people who didn't
consent to it oh that was pretty good
cointelpro
no
i